salut aujourd'hui j'ai un invité sur la
chaîne du mental blog et s'est invité
ses sait qui c'est moi c'est un plaisir
en tant que magicien d'en rencontrer un
mentaliste et c'est ça rarement il est
magicien tu as une chaîne depuis quand
même tarn c'est çà ou là alors motion
j'ai mon compte youtube depuis après
2009 je crois [ __ ] c'est très très
vieux jeu je fais venir armand à la
maison déjà ça fait longtemps qu'on se
connaît on voulait faire une vidéo
ensemble mais on a cherché longtemps tu
me devais même envoyé des super
proposition et je crois qu'au final le
plus intéressant c'est de faire ce qu'on
a fait comme avec rage l'auto disciples
pour le yes man et tout ça c'est de
venir discuter avec toi des tours de
magie des beaux tours de magie si on va
en voir il suffit de cliquer là et ça
vous emmène sur la chaîne directement
d'armand tu vasculaire la saison ont
fait ils sont fait donc aller les voir
ils sont super cool qu'est ce que
j'aimerais parler c'est justement de toi
de ton point de vue de magicien je sais
que le truc n'est qu'une toute petite
partie de ton tour en tout cas je pense
à bonbons pas du tout du mec au delà du
truc qui a il ya quelque chose qui est
très important qui même primordial quand
tu présentes un tour de magie
c'est l'histoire que tu va raconter
derrière et ça en général j'essaie
toujours de deux mois raconté une
histoire derrière un tour de magie en
exemple de ma vidéo qui marche le mieux
sur sur ma chaîne c'est celle où
j'embrasse des filles l'histoire là
dedans c'est que tu as une histoire un
peu romantique parce que c'est un tour
de magie qui fait que tu vas pouvoir
embrasser une fille ça donne un petit
côté féerique autour les faits ou les
cartes vont s'échanger derrière ça je
rajoute là que je rajoute pas le fait
que là le signe la fille signe sa carte
fait que je signe moi même la carte
qu'on les mette dans nos bouches qu'on
s'embrasse et que la sas échange je crée
une vraie mise en scène avec une vraie
petite histoire que tes amis c'est comme
d'hab cinéma on appelle ça un enjeu en
fait c'est à dire que là il ya un enjeu
le fait d'embrasser la fille tu vas au
final donc c'est ainsi un enjeu il ya un
espèce se noue de stress de l'autre côté
à savoir il va y arriver ou pas parce
que tu aurais pu faire la même chose
avec les cartes posées dans les mains et
c'est ce que je fais d'ailleurs très
souvent sa maman ça me permet de voir
justement les réactions et je peux
t'assurer que la réaction quand quand on
embrasse la fille que tu fais le tour de
magie
elle est beaucoup plus spectaculaire est
petite parenthèse parce qu'on ne sait
jamais il n'a jamais forcé personne à
l'embrasser à chaque fois regardez la
vidéo
c'est un truc cool et
respectueux envers les filles tellement
de polémique à ce moment je préfère
juste le précise et non en général j'en
parle déjà avant avec lé avec la fille
avant je ne la tient pas comme ça
écoutons dégage de la conversation je
vous fais le récap parce que ça ça va
peut-être vous paraître plus clair mais
voilà il ya la technique du magicien au
départ il ya l'idée de base qui est
transposé de cartes
après il ya le fait de choisir un angle
hyper intéressant qui est sûre toute
l'histoire de la séduction etc qui
donnent un vrai un vrai enjeu en fait
autour il ya le fait de rajouter en
subtilité les signatures qui casse un
chemin magique
une explication possible qui est des
cartes en double puisque ça les rend
uniques
là on voit tout le travail qui se dégage
en fait ça voilà c'est pas juste un
magicien qui ont ce carte qui va dans la
rue et qui bosse à l'impossibilité
magique en elle-même elle suffit pas
après ça devient un casse-tête en fait
qu'est-ce que tu recommanderait à
quelqu'un qui voudrait se mettre à la
magie aujourd'hui il est des trois
conseils d'armand pour quelqu'un qui
veut se mêler la même - conseil d'ami
je dois avouer que déjà ne pas faire
comme moi ne pas dire beaucoup livre
parce que j'avoue que ne pas avoir lu
énormément livre on a en magie et c'est
vrai que les livres je commence à me
prendre des livres un peu un peu
intéressant pour me plonger dedans parce
qu'ils seraient que des leafs est très
utile pour des magiciens mais je pense
que tu recommandera la même chose je
voulais ça juste avant que c'est beau et
donc voilà il ya des livres très bon
pour débuter dans la magie je sais que
j'ai beaucoup entendu parler des livres
de robert tokyo oui oui mais tu vas
hivernaux si un autre conseil que je
pourrais donner
c'est de passer des heures à s'entraîner
il ya bien un truc à faire quand quand
tu veux te lancer dans la magie c'est de
prendre d après midi dont on entend dans
ta vie et de prendre tes cartes et
recommencer des choses pendant des
centaines de fois tu recommences des
manipulations comme ça moi je le faisais
ça beaucoup quand j'étais devant la télé
tu sais en regardant la télé tu peux
faire soi même temps moi si j'ai un
conseil à rajouter s'est fait rapidement
des tours à des gens que vous connaissez
pas et pas votre famille ou vos
meilleurs amis
parce qu'en fait à ce moment là tu
prends le rôle d'un magicien mais où ils
savent que t'es pas magicien je sais que
c'était 3-2 qu'on sait que j'avais dit
oui c'était vraiment ça aïe ça ça marche
pas puisque en fait mais ils connaissent
d'avant que tu fasses de la magie et
donc à part vouloir embêter commencé à
tout fouillé tous touchés tout mélanger
et est met des bâtons dans ces moments
là mais ça veut dire quelqu'un vous
connaissez pas il va être est allé dans
la rue c'est ça c'est à dire c'est une
fois les dans la rue il faut dire
bonjour choisi est ce que ça vous
dérange vous montre un petit tour de
magie comme ça je vous demande pas
d'argent et tout le moins c'est juste
pour le fun et puis vous vous entraînez
vous allez avec de vous trouver des amis
cause de ça qui donne le remaniement
ratage la même passion vous et puis vous
tout simplement vous avez faire des
verts des gens vous connaissez pas vous
montrer des petits tours de cartes
n'attendait pas le tour de ouf pour vous
entraînez vous faire un tour parce qu'en
fait c'est vous qui trouve ses cinq
tours donc c'est comment vous allez à
mener votre tour qui va qui va donner ce
côté ou photos c'est que je fais des
tours de magie qui sont des tours des
fois très banal détour mais que magicien
m20f et aux autos pas droit de faire ça
c'est tellement nul et des gens des fois
j'en fais en soirée et ses tours là qui
ont des fois la meilleure grille carrée
à la clé même la meilleure réaction
parce que tu viens déjà de prouver que
tu étais un bon magicien si tu fais un
petit tour derrière qui peut paraître
banal selon la façon dont tulameen il
peut être au final extraordinaire pour
le spectateur
merci beaucoup armand j'espère que cette
discussion avec un vrai magicien chair
et en os kkk une chouette chaîne vous a
plu c'est à dire c'est du plastique mec
assez aisément une bosse et aimante et
allez allez faire un tour sur la chaîne
d'armand regarder les vidéos jeux on se
retrouve à la voir ce que on a fait une
petite vidéo aussi sur ma chaîne il ment
on va la faire mais oui c'est vrai ben
oui oui j'avais oublié
dans la foulée merci beaucoup d'avoir
écouté cette conversation merci armand
c'était passionnant avec plaisir cool
c'est merci à toi de l'invitation mais
je t'en supplie et puis vous n'oubliez
surtout pas de vous abonner à la chaîne
avant de partir puisque le mental boxe
et une vidéo par jour pendant un an
jusqu'au 31 décembre
donc le rendez vous demain à 17 heures
ne loupez aucune de ces petites vidéos
et lui là tous les jours merci mon vote
ciao